Prasad and this is my leukemia gene
expression project or machine learning
so I chose this project because I was
interested in learning about leukemia
gene expression and to possibly create a
model that could accurately predict
cancers versus normal tissue depending
on gene expression I also was curious to
see which genes would be predicted to be
the most significant in gene expression
of leukemia
um I'm so sorry I have concussion so
please forgive me if I misspeak a little
bit but to start my question was can you
distinguish cancerous tissues from
normal tissue and if so which genes are
important for distinguishing the two
um my hypothesis or I guess prediction
was I do believe that it's possible to
distinguish cancerous tissues from
normal tissues and creating a model that
can do so
um and using that model I think we can
also find specific genes that are
predictors or biomarkers that can be
helpful in the future for diagnostic
tools
um so for the research or the background
acute myeloid leukemia is an acute blood
cancer that starts in your bone marrow
it develops as a result of genetic
changes in the hematopoetic precursor
cell which results in accumulation of
immature myeloid cells in the bone
marrow and peripheral blood this
mutation occurs in both oncogenes and
tumor suppressor genes it can be caused
by a variety of genes I wanted to create
a model that could differentiate between
normal and cancerous tissues and
potentially be used to predict
biomarkers related to acute myeloid
leukemia and this is by doing or by
using machine learning techniques this
predictive model could be used to
distinguish these types for the data set
that I use I actually used
it had cancer tissue which is referred
to as AML and then the normal tissue is
broken into a few different classes
peripheral blood blood marrow and then
cdk 34 plus which is a well-known
embryonic
cell cell line and that's specifically
broken further into peripheral blood and
bone marrow and I will be discussing it
more in the next slide actually oh sorry
this side after that
um so my testing method so I actually
started without a visualization I did a
heat map I also checked distribution of
the classes in the data I also did
um PCA to conduct or was conducted to
see how much variance is explained I
also combined the two subclasses of
cdk34 plus to see how it affected the
PCA and grouping which we'll see like
later on in the slideshow
before using a classification method I
also used a lazy predict to determine
the best model from this I saw that
random force was the best model which is
a bit of a spoiler
um and I use that to model the data uh
next I did feature selection which was
to identify the top genes that were
um the top genes that were used in the
random Forest classification model and
then also those were the potential
biomarkers with that classification
system I ended with auto encoders just
to explain the variance a little bit
better and for dimensionality reduction
and to get a better view of the data
overall
so just to kind of start uh this is my
heat map of the data
um from this you can kind of see a few
different things the first thing that
you'll notice is that
um the uh the there are actual like
differences in the expression of each of
the genes if you look at the lines I
know it's a little bit small and it's
just because there are a lot of like uh
genes used in this
um
uh so sorry I don't know what's going on
with my mouse
but that's kind of basically all that
there is it's really just that there are
um like differences in gene expression
between all the genes and it's
consistent between some of the samples
and some of the genes like they appear
to be more in a straight line which you
can kind of see I don't know if you can
see my mouse but you can kind of see it
around here and then there's others that
are a little bit more kind of like
spread out there's less consistent
expression levels uh there's like dotted
lines or chunks of different colors in
one of the like straight columns or
bands for example right around here you
can see it goes like lighter and then
goes to a dark indicating less
expression and then lighter and it keeps
going like that where it's kind of
broken up into chunks like that
uh next we have the PCA plot so with
this PCA plot this is the plot that
actually has all of the subclasses on it
so uh we see the plot that all the
normal tissue is nicely clustered
together and so is the cancer tissue uh
although it's spread out like the cancer
tissue itself the AML which is the red
dots has spread out a little bit more
throughout the plot however only 34 of
the variance is explained um and I
actually did calculate how many PCA
components are need to needed to explain
80 of the variance which is the
threshold usually and it's 22 components
um there is still some nice uh
clustering or grouping I guess that's
being done but I I did think it would be
best to do auto encoders just to kind of
explain that variance a little bit
better
um as you can see the the peripheral
blood is kind of Plus or grouped up here
the the pink is the bone marrow group
the dark blue is the bone marrow cd34
and then the dark green is the pbsc
which is the peripheral blood for the
cdk 34 cells and then the red is the
leukemia cells or sorry the cancer
stitches so and then this is the updated
PCA I actually ended up kind of after
doing a distribution I noticed that
there was a difference of samples
between the AML samples and then the
different subclass of the normal samples
so I decided to combine the two
different categories of cd34 cells in
one variable with both just to kind of
see what would happen I was just a
little bit curious and additionally I
also thought cd34k cells could be one
General category as I wasn't as
interested in looking at them to be
honest
um but I also just wanted to kind of see
what would happen the variances still
ends up being around 34 that's being
explained anyways
there wasn't really too much of a
difference in the plot
um and there's still like 22 components
that needed are needed to explain 80 of
the variance uh there's still like some
pretty nice clustering just different
colors of course so we still have that
peripheral blood up here the leukemia
still kind of spread out throughout the
thing or throughout the plot I mean the
bone marrow is now split
um here and then a little bit up here
which is a little bit interesting and
the cd34 is kind of just in the middle
between the bone marrow groups
um but yeah I just I this was just a
little experiment and I went back to
manipulating the original data after
that and I actually did lazy predict
um so with lazy predict it's a way to
kind of see the best classification
method it's running a different a ton of
different classification methods you can
kind of compare it based off of the
parameters that's given accuracy balance
accuracy F1 score and then the time
taken
so from this model this is the top 10 I
noticed that random forces on that and
that is one of the classifier methods
that we talked about in class so I just
chose to use that we also can just tell
for the parameters for all of them
they're pretty well or pretty good I
should say
um ignoring time taken for the other
three if it's closer to one it's better
um time taken you don't want a
classification method that's going to
take an extremely long period of time so
the first one was LG uh BM classifier
even though all the values or all the
other parameters are the highest that
time taken is definitely a detraction
it's not something that you should do so
we can kind of also it's not a model
we've really talked about in class so I
just ignored that um I did see random
four so I thought that was interesting I
wanted to try it and also the parameters
for that were pretty high still
um time taking was a little bit higher
than some of the other ones but not too
big of a deal compared to the like the
first model having such a large time
taken
so like I said I did random Forest uh
this is the classification report that
was done I used a test sample or test
size of about 25
um and when I actually did it I got 100
accuracy with the model
um which I thought was pretty cool for
the classification report just for some
background Precision is the ratio of two
positives to Total positives and
essentially refers to accuracy so a
higher Precision score is going to
indicate indicate a lower rate of false
positives recalls the ratio of two
positives to all the actual observations
so a total true pauses and false so so
sorry so the true or the total of the
true pauses and false negatives and
essentially refers to sensitivity of the
model the F1 score is the weighted
average of precision and recall so it
takes the false positives and false
negatives into account uh F1 score is
one of the most program or most
important parameters as it can be more
useful than Precision just because it's
taking into account false positives and
false negatives and then support is a
number of occurrences with each class so
for this it's not as important we see
that all the parameters except support
are one for each the types of tissues so
this classification method worked really
well
um but yeah
here's a heat map that kind of visually
shows this we see that for all of them
it's the model accuracy at the top I
have a little screenshot it is one who
are 100 and you can see in the confusion
Matrix all of the samples were
classified properly and where it should
be which was great to see and this is
using the original data set not that one
that I combined
so next I did feature selection whoo so
this was kind of interesting when I did
feature selection
I looked at the top
um five uh genes from this and you can
see the top five significant jeans I
have like the name that they have but I
also actually ended up looking them up
just to kind of get the official G name
so those genes in order correspond to
myh 10 pcdh9 tspy L5 cd79a and ccna1
just for some background myh 10 encodes
Myerson which is an important for
cytokinesis which is an important part
of the cell cycle that gets disregulated
with cancer because usually cell cycle
um it with cytokinesis that's the
breaking apart when the cells are being
formed and there's actually issues of
cell proliferation in uh patients who
have AML
uh PCD H9 encodes a protocadron which is
important for cell adhesion and neuronal
cell tissues and signaling at neuronal
synaptic Junctions this one was the most
interesting to me just because I didn't
really see as much of a link to AML with
this one um I'm sure I probably missed
something
um that is a little bit more clear to
doctors or people more well-versed with
oncology
um but I just thought that was kind of
interesting tsp yl5 is involved in
modulation of cell growth and involved
in regulation of p53 which is a very
crucial tumor suppressor Gene so I
thought that was also pretty fascinating
cd79a is a protein coding Gene involved
in B lymphocyte antigen receptors which
is important in the immune system
response and it has also been found to
be upregulated in cancer patients and
then finally ccna1 is encode Cyclones
that are important for cell cycle
regulation they're really crucial for
that and it's something that gets
dysregulated in cancer and so looking at
those top five genes the CCNA one gene
was found also found to be in the
associated publication to be related to
AML specific expression changes so that
was pretty interesting because that
indicates it's definitely a good
biomarker for differentiating between
cancerous tissues and normal tissues
just because it is associated with AML
specific expression changes so that was
the first interesting I think I saw
uh the next thing I did was Auto
encoders which
um basically with the auto encoders I
was kind of just trying to
understand
um oh well here's the graph I should
probably start off with that first but
basically you can see from the above
graphs that the first one I did was 50
features and the next one I did was 100
features you see that the 100 features
are built and 75 of the variance
explained and it also has
um a much better
um Mae essentially so with this you see
uh that the there's a drop with the
epochs down to about 40 as in both of
the graphs like regardless of the number
of features the mean absolute error was
low for both those training and testing
data and we want that training and
testing data to have like similar low
values
um just because that means the mean
arrow is the lowest there so we also see
looking at the PCA plot we see some nice
grouping for all the classes again but
it's really um good that the PCA plots
with 100 features is now explaining 75
of the variance which is much closer to
that threshold of 80 that I was talking
about and here's kind of my explanation
for that I just kind of went through
anyways but like I said we see from
those graphs that 100 features are sold
in 75 variance explained that's close to
the 80 threshold and then 100 features
is better for explaining the variants
and you can drop down the amount of
epochs down to around 40 just because it
it results in a lower
um mean obsoever
so my discoveries uh so basically
I I noticed a few interesting things
actually so the first thing is that
random Force classification produced a
model with 100 accuracy with a small
test size so it shows that the accuracy
is not due to overfitting by using a
larger test size which is pretty nice at
least
um the auto encoders explained 75 of the
variance which was much more than was
explained originally with just the PCA
plots which was about 34 it's also much
close to that threshold of 80 and then
feature selection showed some of the
more significant genes actually picked
out one that was was related to AML
specific expression changes and was
found in a publication to be that way
um this was pretty interesting because
my question originally was can you
distinguish cancerous tissues from
normal tissue and if so which gene or
importance for distinguishing you are
able to create a model that could
accurately classify Cancers and normal
tissues using gene expression data and
it also did pick out the top five genes
that could be biomarkers those genes
specifically were fascinating just
because they're all to some extent
involved in the cell cycle or immune
system and those both affect this spread
of cancer and regulation of cancer so
that means that they could actually be
some pretty interesting biomarkers to
further explore especially because
finding ccna1 as significant in the
classification method as
it was also significant in the
publication it kind of validates the
fact that it's very important for
differentiate differentiating tissue
types
um overall looks like rainforest is a
good modeling Choice there looks uh if
looking to differentiate between the
tissue types but the variance is
explained as well so you kind of need to
supplement with autoencoders and then
those five significant genes that I was
talking about should really be further
explored like I said take away machine
learning models can be used to fairly
accurately predict cancer sources
non-cancerous tissues with regard to ml
and have been or can be used to identify
potential new biomarkers that could be
used diagnostically the conclusion like
I said random force is an accurate
classification method for this data set
can be used to predict tissue
differentiation not enough variances
explained by PCA so autoencoders is used
as a supplement to kind of explain more
the variants and then feature suction is
important for finding those biomarkers
genes that are that can be further
explored what can be done next like I
said further exploration of those genes
picked up by random Force to see if they
could be used by biomarkers and if there
are any other significant and other
classification methods would be pretty
interesting to look at just because
those genes are already involved with
cancer and the immune system and cell
regulation that it's definitely a
fascinating topic to look into because
they might be more involved in the
future it could be pretty useful if they
are discovered to be involved in other
data sets I guess with more data bigger
data I would say then you might actually
be able to use as a diagnostic method
and a diagnostic tool added to a genetic
testing panel when you're testing to see
if a patient could be
more at risk for having cancer or
specifically ml in this scenario
that's about it uh this is my references
uh thank you for your time and I
apologize if I didn't make sense at any
point I'm suffering from a concussion at
the moment
um but thank you